well let's take you now to brussels
where european leaders are speaking
after four days of talks
on the coronavirus recovery package
there you're listening now
to european council president shall
michelle let's
have a listen to what he's saying
collective responsibility
and solidarity and we show
also our belief in our common future
and this agreement sends a concrete
signal that
europe is a force for action
we negotiate it about money but of
course
it's about a lot more than money
it's about workers and families their
jobs
their health and their well-being
i believe this agreement will be seen
as a pivotal moment in europe's
journey but it will also launch us
into the future in fact it's the first
time
the first time in european history that
our budget
will be clearly linked to our climate
objectives the first time the first time
that the respect for rule of law
is a decisive criteria for budget
spending
and the first time the first time
that you are jointly reinforcing our
economies
against a crisis
[Music]
well you've been listening there to
european council president shel michelle
it's he's speaking now after four days
and four nights
of marathon often acrimonious talks
leaders at the eu have finally clinched
a deal on a multi-billion dollar
coronavirus rescue fund
now that recovery package we understand
will provide almost 860 billion dollars
and grants and loans to counter the
effects of the recession that we've been
seeing set in there had been huge
divisions over just how much
of this package should be loans how much
should take the form of grants that
don't need to be repaid they finally
agreed and that was a unanimous decision
that was agreed um in the early hours of
this morning
well we can now speak to our
correspondent steph vassen she joins
me on the phone now from amsterdam step
four day is four nights of infighting
finally a deal can you talk us through
just what's been agreed here
yes finally they have this 27 signatures
and it was indeed a long and dramatic
summit more than four days and nights as
you say
but it is a deal a historic deal and it
will
also strengthen the the economic
strength of
the european union and that's of course
the reason why the countries were very
keen to uh to sign the deal although it
was
very very difficult 750 billion euros
for this massive aid package and it will
go mostly
to the countries who were affected the
most in the south of europe mostly
italy of course i'm so sorry to
interrupt you we will come back to you
shortly
but shall michelle is speaking in
english um in brussels and we're going
to listen into that and we'll come back
to you shortly thanks
i've been hit by an unprecedented crisis
i think the 600 000 dead was the last
figures i saw a few hours ago this
crisis continues and will continue to
affect
people families women children
as political leaders we have
responsibilities we have
a democratic mandate which we all share
and we have to answer that challenge by
showing that we are able
to deal with these through
concrete real results and through
decisions
concreteness not virtual this is a
decision
which will have an impact it must have
an impact a positive impact
so that we can move towards the future
and
meet our challenges thank you madam
president
merci beaucoup
for his really hard work and his
tremendous
perseverance because the success of this
european
council is his success as well i'd like
to thank angela merkel
for her exceptional guidance
we spent four long days and nights of
negotiation
more than 90 hours but it was worth it
this agreement is a signal that europe
is
able to act now in german after all um
people often accuse europe as being too
little too late whereas here we're
demonstrating that the opposite is the
case
at the end of april the european council
gave us
the mandate of designing a recovery
package and today
two only two months later next
generation europe
is up and running and it has the
agreement of the european council
and in the history of the european union
that is an absolute
record for a new budgetary instrument
and next generation europe is very
extensive more than 1.8 trillion euros
and that's more than
5 of the gdp
of the eu 27.
europe still has the courage and the
imagination to
think big and in so doing
we are fully aware
that this is a historic moment in europe
we are currently in one of the most
difficult
economic and health crises but
nonetheless
europe is managing
having worked really hard to tackle this
crisis in a really effective way
and this will benefit the eu budget and
it will link
solidarity with responsibility
solidarity
because all 27 countries together
bear and support next generation eu and
responsibility
because next generation eu doesn't just
point the way out of the crisis but also
it serves the very foundation of a
modern
and sustainable europe i want to
emphasize
two more points we have now
the new own resources tightly linked to
the repayment
this is a big step forward with a clear
timetable
member states will benefit as they will
contribute less
to repay the investments
and the new owned resources will
strengthen the european union
also in the long term i'm glad
that we managed to safeguard this
achievement during the whole
negotiations
and europe's recovery will be green
the new budget will power the european
green deal
it will accelerate the digitalization of
europe's economy
thanks to next generation eu national
reforms will be boosted
we invest in europe's future
and finally unlike
in previous crisis this time
member states have not opted
for an intergovernmental agreement but
they have entrusted the european
commission
of europe's recovery we will together
manage a total of
1.8 trillion euro
the bulk of the money will be channeled
through the programs in which the
european parliament is involved
next generation eu comes with a great
responsibility
and we are determined to bring about
reforms
and investment in europe nevertheless i
must also mention a difficult
point in their search for compromise
leaders have
made far-reaching adjustments into the
new
mff and next generation you for example
in health migration external action
invest you
they have not taken up the solvency
instrument
this is regrettable it decreases
the innovative part of the budget even
if more than 50 percent of the overall
budget
mff and next generation eu will support
modern policies and so finally
to conclude europe as a whole
has now a big chance to come out
stronger from the crisis
today we've taken a historic step we can
be all proud of but another
important step remains ahead of us first
and foremost we now have to work with
the european parliament
to secure agreement we have a lot of
work ahead of us
but tonight is a big step forward
towards recovery thank you
thank you madam president we'll be
taking a couple of questions
um and first on is david carretta
david merci david carretta
impossible initial proposals the
commission and you yourself had
had did you sacrifice the rule of law
and the altar of compromise and secondly
[Music]
with so little money will you be able to
carry through your products uh 100
billion
less in the recovery plan and
through the european budget
which generation if any is going to get
this
well i'll try to cover both points
on the rule of law we are fully
determined
and this is the first time in the
history that there is this link between
government
and mobilizes our funds in the rule of
law and mobilizing the funds we've shown
that
the council works on a qualified
majority it's very early in the morning
when you've had more time to read the
details you'll see how ambitious this
compromise is
around the table people spoke frankly
looked at each other in the eyes
and tackled this issue to progress
our common values move them forward move
governance forward i reaffirmed this was
ambitious
and this was an ambitious decision
and then on the amounts can i also say
this is the first time this european
project we've negotiated
such a big financial package
people are giving the impression that
there aren't many resources no there's
1.74
and then 750 billion
in the recovery which together add up to
something that is very substantial we
talk about our ambitions but you have to
look at what the
mff contains to deal with
short medium and long-term strategic
challenges
with this massive injection of
boost the 750 billion euros to
help economic recovery but
also to help transform this european
project
covered 19 has hit us but even before
the commission and parliament
and the council had thought that it was
time to
relaunch and transform
europe with climate change at the heart
of it and
30 of the mff and the recovery fund
have to be tied to these climate
ambitions
and we followed up on what we intended
to do before this all started
and i say with great conviction that
these decisions we've taken today
will transform the in a long-term way
the the face of europe so the questions
um
the text that has been agreed on the
rule of law
has improved um it's a very clear in the
document a very clear commitment to the
rule of law
and a very clear commitment to the
protection
of the financial interests of the union
and this is linked against this
background
to the fact that the commission has
proposed an instrument under which
in case of breaches measures will be
adopted
so there's a very clear link a reference
the adopting or the voting will be by
qualified majority voting
and finally we will also introduce
instruments
to strengthen the controls of the eu
funds so there is more clarity there is
more distinction in the text and the
very clear reference
which was important not only to the rule
of law but also to the protection of the
financial interests
of the union and what the overall
package is concerned and your question
on the priorities for the european union
it has it is an unprecedented size and
scope
of package that we have
1.8 trillion and
the importance here is that the whole
next generation generation eu package
of 750 billion is composed in a way
that the national recovery plans will be
aligned with
the european priorities that is the
european green deal
that is the digitization that is
resilience
transmitted through the country's
specific recommendations
so we have a very strong tool now
that we can work together with the
member states
on not only the recovery but at the same
time
through the investment leap forward
into a more sustainable a greener and
more digitized
future we want to build with a modern
single market so this is a unique
opportunity to modernize the european
union
thank you next question is for uh david
harzenhorn
from politico thank you very much brent
good morning president president
michelle i wonder if you could address
the concern that president fonderline
just raised calling it regrettable
that leaders had to cut some of the most
innovative parts
of the mff also that
you had to persist in the rebates which
some people
feel are sort of a budget gimmick uh in
uh getting agreement here and if there
was a moment in this for you
uh president michelle when uh throughout
this summit what was the key moment when
you had a deal and for president
thunderline
a lot of this uh package obviously will
be in national
uh plans the grants that was the uh
issue of disagreement to your mind how
do you envision
member states best using these grants in
concrete ways obviously it's not like
rebuilding from an earthquake
or from a war it's a different type of
recovery in a concrete way what do you
envision the best national recovery
plans might look like
thank you
there is a very strong political will
around the table of
the european council uh to to act
to act in order to deliver because uh
we we are convinced uh that uh climate
change
that innovation that the support for the
social
economy for example it's key to develop
a very strong program and with
this decision the mff and the recovery
fund we have the tools we have the means
in order to tackle those important
challenges for for the future
it's also important to to observe that
this package
is huge if you compare if you compare to
the cipher
of the europe of the european gdp also
important not to forget
that the recovery strategy will also
be developed at the national level it
means
that s european union you
you you we send a very strong signal
we are solid we are robust and
we are united and more than ever we need
to be united and we need to be strong in
order to face
this huge crisis
so to your question reforming
concerning the part
how i envisaged to make sure that the
investment goes in the right direction
the program is the recovery and
resilience facility is established in a
way
that is very clear first of all
it's voluntary so member states can
choose
to come forward with a national recovery
plan
but it has to be aligned with the
european semester and they are the
country-specific recommendations
and country specific recommendations
address
the weak weaknesses or deficiencies in
member states that should be
improved where things should be reformed
and they were always very interesting
but did
not always have the necessary
effect in the member states because it
was up to them to implement them or not
now this instruments has a new punch
because the european semester is now
connected to an enormous amount of
grants
or potentially loans so there's way more
punch behind
the country-specific recommendations and
the necessity to respect
the principles of the european green
deal and of the digitization as i set
the priorities of the european union
we can make sure that this will be
implemented in a proper way because
there will be milestones
where you have a look whether the
milestones have been reached and then
the necessary investment the the
payments will be dispersed
so there's a very clear plan to
have the both two goals on the one hand
the recovery of the member state but on
the other hand
to make sure that it's at the same time
a modernization
of the member states
thank you next question is for sun
fleming from the financial times
yes good good morning bye can i follow
up on the question
on my fees on rebates
um the clearly the rebates were
only maintained from previous drafts um
but they were actually increased
were the frugal states in these
discussions effectively trading their
support for
higher grants in exchange for higher
rebates uh were you disappointed
that that was the outcome that you saw
given the commission has previously
been recommending that rebates be phased
out
and do you think rebates now these high
rebates are basically here to stay
thank you
we took a decision today
for the next mff and for the recovery
fund
uh and in the framework of this decision
we took also some decisions
related to the to the rebates uh if we
face
a big crisis i repeat again and i see
that what's important is the fact that
we find uh we find the the way
in order to to take a very strong
decision and indeed
the rebates it's not a surprise when
i uh expressed the idea a few weeks
ago that we we will we would need
uh to tackle different building blocks i
express the idea
that we base would be part of the global
package of the global decision
you you know at the level of the open
council is very difficult we need to
decide by unanimity
and that's why it's important to show
respect for each other that's why it's
important
also to be able at the same time to take
strong
and courageous decisions and that's what
we did
today and i remember only a few hours
ago maybe
and certainly the last days there was
this global impression that it would be
impossible mission but we did it and
it's very important we were able to
to take the decision we are united and
we sent the message
europe is strong
next question is for lilly bayer
please lily thank you
much question which is uh for both
presidents
today it's not really the end of the
saga because of course you still need to
convince the european parliament
and national parliaments to sign off on
this deal
so i was wondering if you could both
maybe talk a little bit
about how you plan to convince like
to sign off especially because we're
already seeing some members of the
european parliament
raising concerns about certain elements
of your package
thank you
we we show we show respect for the
important role
of the european uh parliament
and uh as you know we had many
consultations many
contexts with the european parliament
the last weeks the last
the last month and and of course we will
have the the occasion
uh to uh to to to to maintain the the
distributions
with the members of the european
parliament and it's key
for the european democratic process
of course and at the same time you are
right we need also
to show respect for the responsibility
of the
national parliaments man today there is
a strong signal there is a strong
message
why because 27 head of states
and out of governments they took the
decision to act together
and they are responsible before the
their own
national parliament i know that probably
uh because it's the democratic process
it will be difficult
uh it will mean that we will need to to
explain what are the arguments
what are the reasons for our uh decision
we
we are transparent it's also very
essential
for this democratic process uh and
i'm really uh convinced that with
political will with potential courage
uh with a constant dialogue it will be
possible to implement
what we have decided today well indeed
from tomorrow on
well you've been listening there to eu
leaders speaking in brussels after
four days and four nights of tense talks
about their budget which
this time includes a deal for a nearly
860 billion dollar pandemic rescue
package now this was also the first
in-person meeting
since the start of the pandemic and
there's been huge division over
how much of that money would be grants
versus loans as
well as whether eu funding should be
linked to the rule of law we've been
hearing from charles michel the
president of the european council and
ursula von delane
the president of the european commission
they've been reiterating
the unity and solidarity of the eu both
describing it as a next
generation european union especially an
emphasis on
green investments as they focus on their
attempted economic recovery
well let's now speak to our
correspondent step bass and she joins me
now on the phone
from amsterdam step after more than 90
hours of negotiation as bondelaine was
saying that
we finally have a deal a historic deal
can you talk us through what's been
agreed here
yes you heard the word mission
impossible several times
of course during this press conference
and it is indeed
a big victory for the european uh
council president
charles michelle because the future of
the eu
as a unity was basically hanging in his
hands
it is of course a very important sign
that all the 27 countries have signed
this deal because if it would have not
if it would have failed
it would have been dramatic of course
for the european union
and at the end it's a compromise there
was a long battle for four days and four
nights about how
this money would be divided it was a
large
grand package initially before the talk
started but now
most of half of this package is going to
be loans and half of it
is still going to be grants but with
strict conditions and this is a win
for the so-called frugal four countries
uh the smaller
northern european countries like the
netherlands uh sweden denmark and
austria
who have pushed a lot for these strict
conditions
tied to the loans because this to the
grant because they were afraid
that like what happened in the past
economic crisis like in 2008
loss of money would be dispersed and
they would have no control over it
and the countries here at the
netherlands specifically is very much
afraid
that the dutch taxpayers are paying too
much
that money is going to be misspent so
they have this kind of
emergency break that they agreed on that
if a country
is not spending the money in the right
way that the other countries can
intervene and can stop the disbursement
of the
money so this is an important win for
the smaller countries and it was
dramatic because
they were in a conflict with the france
and germany the big
eu countries and there were dramatic
moments when
manuel macron was already starting his
plane
in the last couple of days pretending
that he was gonna leave uh but he wasn't
at the last uh
moment so there was a lot of drama in
this uh summit
but as i said it was so important for
the 27
countries of the eu to make this deal
there was also a compromise on this
rule of law agreement as you heard in
the press conference
hungary and poland were very uh much
against
a tightening of this money to the
country's rule of law
and also the smaller countries were
protesting against it they wanted
that countries need to prove that they
have this rule of law before they get
any money
and then they were referring to poland
and hungary so they made a compromise
on that but as sean michel in the press
conference that he was still very
pleased with the outcome uh and all the
details will make that clear
so it is a historic uh moment here and a
historic
outcome of this of this summit step as
you say it's definitely a compromise and
certain richer countries still are very
unhappy about this idea of shared debt
but i believe we're now looking at a
first for the eu selling collective
bonds and then
giving the proceeds and grants is that a
precedent for
how things could work going forward
definitely
it it is the first and it is of course a
huge
package of money we're talking in total
about 1.8 trillion
euros and a lot of it will be borrowed
on the on the financial
capital markets here in europe which is
also the first uh
method to do it this way uh and there is
this shared responsibility yes it is the
the first and that's why of course the
european leaders were so uh
talking about victory uh it is it is
difficult but it's also very difficult
time everyone
the countries are also facing at this
economic uh recession uh
due to the covet-19 crisis so there was
this
this feeling that they had to act now
and if not there would be a huge crisis
coming up in the next couple of years
and of course we still have to see if
this is going to be enough
to uh to make to prevent this from
happening because uh
spain italy greece they're all they're
struggling uh
deeply so this is going to be a huge
test also for the european union to see
if they can actually
do this all together step you talked
about some of the drama that we've seen
over the last few days i mean this was
the longest eu summit since by my
account
nice back in 2000 we saw some frayed
tempers gloves
even masks coming off and it felt like
it really illustrated the divisions that
we've seen emerged during this pandemic
and also during brexit
so where does this leave the whole
european project now
yes it was very dramatic as i said there
were moments that there were
fish banks on the table especially the
dutch prime minister
was very much criticized and a name
called he was called mr nono and and bad
guy and mr stingy because
he played hardball in in brussels uh
he was one of the leaders of this this
movement that
went against uh the majority of the
european union who
actually wanted a much more uh to show
more solidarity as they said to the
southern countries
so there was this divide and it was very
painful because
uh italy uh for example and and spain
they felt
left uh left behind they feel they felt
like northern countries didn't want to
help them in this very difficult crisis
and of course nobody asked for covet 19
and it
you can't be blamed for being affected
by it so it was
it became very emotional but the fact
that they actually got
out of it is definitely a good sign and
and i think that will definitely
strengthen the mood in there in the eu
which
was already at a very low point because
when they were dealing with government
19
everyone every single country was doing
their own thing they had their own
policy
so there was not much of a unity and
hopefully now they
will show that they actually do need
each other
well we'll be bringing you all the
details of that historic deal in the
coming hours here on al jazeera our
correspondent step bass in there
speaking to us from amsterdam thank you
steph